[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN CHONG: So good afternoon
and welcome to this session.
My name is Ben Chong.
I'm a product manager
on Cloud Storage.
So my primary mission
and goal in life right
now is to help you guys
get your data onto GCP.
Today we have a bunch of
slide, so let's keep questions
until the end.
And I'll be around if you guys
want to talk to me individually
after the session.
So let's start the
afternoon with talking
about Google's mission.
I think you guys may
have heard this already.
So our mission is to organize
the world's information
and to make it universally
accessible and useful.
And to achieve this mission,
we have built this really big,
complex, advance
global architecture
and infrastructure.
And with a Cloud
Platform, we are basically
making this same set of
tools and infrastructure
available to you so
that you can also
organize your
company's information
and make it accessible and
useful, right, with machine
learning, BigQuery, and so on.
Now the key though, in order
to use all these tools that
are available on Cloud
Platform is that you
need to get your data in.
Your company's information needs
to be brought onto GCP so they
can run BigQuery, you can
use the new Spanner tools,
and so on.
I mean, we'll kind of
covered that today.
So let's cover two types of data
sources and two types of data.
First, let's talk about
unstructured data.
So unstructured
data is what we call
files, files that are on
your file system in your data
center.
And structured
data are databases,
whether it's big data, or
MySQL databases, and so on.
Let's start with
unstructured data first.
So when we talk about
unstructured data
on Cloud Platform, it's
basically Google Cloud Storage.
So that's where
unstructured data lives.
We all know it.
I hope we all love it as well.
Think of it as your
Cloud Hard Drive.
So like GCE may be your
CPU and Cloud Storage
is your hard drive.
We have two classes of storage,
Multi-Regional and Regional
for live data, so data
that changes all the time
that you're using
for compute workloads
to serve media content to
your customers and end users.
And then they have two
classes, Nearline and Coldline
for colder storage.
There's the kind of
data that you are not
planning to touch for
like 30 days, or 90 days,
and it's worth storing
into Nearline or Coldline.
I'm not going to go into
a lot of details here.
There are details online.
There were sessions
earlier this week
that went into some details on
how to use GCS for performance
and so on.
All that content would be
available after the event.
If you have specific questions,
do reach out to your sales
reps.
They're there to
answer your questions.
The next couple of slides covers
kind of like very high level
considerations,
like what should you
think about when you
use Cloud Storage?
So storage tiers, I covered
the four storage tiers.
You're gonna want to make sure
that you choose the right ones
for the right workloads.
It's not the end of the world if
you don't choose the right one.
You can always move data around.
The only thing you
want to make sure
is that if you started off
with objects in Nearline
or Coldline, you
may incur what you
call a deletion charges
if you delete them
before 30 days or 90 days.
Data locality can
depend on two factors.
The data locality is like
where are your consumers,
where's the consumer
of the data.
If the data is going to
be consumed by Compute,
Compute is kind
of like Regional,
like US Central, US
East, in which case,
then you want to make sure
your buckets are nearby.
So you want to choose
regional buckets
versus multi-regional buckets.
And one thing that a lot
of people get caught by
is bucket names are kind of
based on a global namespace.
So you bucket name has
to be pretty unique.
Don't use personally
identifiable information
to name a bucket.
And then you should pre-create
buckets, if necessary,
as opposed to
including the bucket
creation in your workflow.
Additional consideration, so
you've had lots of buckets,
used GUIDs instead of
names, request rates,
if you are planning to do
a lot of write requests,
you want to scale up
instead of like hitting
the system all of a sudden.
We do have some
similarities with S3,
in terms of if you
have sequential names,
you probably don't
want to kind of like
write the objects sequential
names one after another,
because that will impact
performance as well.
So let's go into the meat.
So how do you get data into GCS?
Let's do a show poll
to understand what kind
of networks you guys have.
Who has one gig
networks, like uplink?
OK, 10 gigs?
How many of you don't know
what kind of network you have?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so how quickly and easily
you can upload data into GCS
depends on the kind of network.
So this is what we call laws
of physics and speed of light.
So imagine you have just
a one gig network uplink,
assuming 100% utilization, so
nobody else is doing emails.
If you have one
petabyte of data is
going to take you more
than three months.
So these are considerations.
So a lot of times we
don't think about network
when we're thinking
about moving data.
So my point here is that
let's thinking about network.
Network is part of the
equation of uploading data
into GCS or GCP.
Which brings us
to the next slide.
So here's how we can
look at the world.
So distance to
GCP is the x-axis.
So if your data is in
GCS or in another cloud,
it is closer to GCP.
If your data is on location
with no network at all,
you're kind of like
really far away.
And the y-axis is
the amount of data.
Now if your data is in
GCS, like for example, you
have data in the
bucket in Europe,
you want to move it to the US.
So that's kind of like 0.0.
If your data is
in another cloud,
like S3, you're
not too far away.
And we have a tool called
Transfer Service for that.
What is Transfer Service?
So Cloud Storage
Transfer Service
is essentially a
three step process
to quickly import
online data into GCS.
So it is really good for
moving data from S3 to GCS.
GCS or GCS Transfer,
I was saying
if you have data
from one region,
you can move to another region.
Or if you want to, like
earlier, if you kind of selected
a multi-regional bucket and
you realize that oh, maybe
it's better for that data
to be a regional bucket,
they can use Transfer
Service to do a migration.
Very popular use
cases, right, so we
have customers who
are S3 customers
and we are fine with that.
This is kind of like
open could world.
They back up their
data to GCS, we're
their primary,
secondary backups.
And they use Transfer Service.
Daily, we're talking about
petabytes of data a week.
A lot of customers, again,
compute workloads in S3,
in AWS.
They love BigQuery,
so what they do,
they use Transfer Service
to move their long files
and other data across the
GCS, import into BigQuery.
Transfer Service
allows you to schedule
either one-time transfers
or recurring transfers.
And you can do hourly
transfers as well.
So what is Transfer Service?
Transfer Service is not a
tool that you can install,
it is a Cloud-hosted tool.
So you go to our Cloud Console.
You can find it under
the Storage section,
under called
Transfer, obviously.
When you click on
Transfer, you will
get a list of transfer jobs.
And then if you click on
the Create Transfer Job,
you can then create
a transfer job.
So step one would be
you specify your source.
So it could be a Cloud Google,
GCS bucket, or S3 bucket.
We can actually transfer
from HTTP, HTTPS sources.
And then you can kind
of specify conditions,
so transfer files only
with certain prefixes,
or exclude files with
certain prefixes.
How many of you know
like why prefix is
so important in object storage?
Not many.
So objects storage is kind
of like a flat storage.
So there's no concept of
folder, like physical folders
and directories.
So a lot of customers
they use prefixes
to kind of identifying folders.
So for example, in
your local file system,
you may have
A/B/C/object or file,
where the slashes kind of denote
you're [INAUDIBLE] limitations.
So when you import that file
into GCS, it will be named,
for example, A/B/C/file
name, or object name.
So the directory prefix
becomes part of the file
name or the object name.
And so by using these
prefix conditions,
you can say that OK, I'm going
to transfer only certain files
and certain folders or
directories into GCS.
So another way of defining
source would be Amazon S3.
So you define the, enter the
name of the S3 bucket, access
key ID, and the
secret access key,
and all those things you can
get from the Amazon console.
So step two is where you
identify the destination.
And you do have transfer
options where you override
the destination if it already
exists, or delete objects
at the source, or
you delete objects
if the source object
has been deleted.
So it's kind of like a
synchronization mechanism.
And then finally,
step three is where
you configured to transfer.
You can run it now or you
can run it at a later time,
on a daily basis.
And then when you
click on Create,
and it creates a transfer job,
it gets queued up for running.
So that's Transfer
Service for you.
Obviously tips, I think
there's a recap of earlier.
You can do all these things
and you can create basically
24 transfer jobs,
one hour apart,
so that gets you an
hourly syncing mechanism.
All right so we'll talk
about Transfer Service.
So what if your
data is in the colo,
or in your own data center, but
with good network connectivity.
So for that, we
have a tool, gsutil.
It's all lower case.
So gsutil is our primary
command line tool.
It runs on Windows, Linux, Mac.
It can run on a GCE instance.
You could even run it on a
EC2 instance, if you like.
It's actively maintain,
actively supported,
Unix friendly syntax,
lots of documentation.
There's also a Stack
Overflow discussion.
So performance, gsutil
can run multi-threaded,
so you can have
multiple processes that
will upload data in parallel.
If you have lots of
like large data files,
gsutil can break
up the data files
into chunks to upload
the chunks in parallel.
And then once uploaded, it will
reconstitute the original file
and delete the chunks.
So that's where there's
a caution there.
If you are uploading like
using this feature to upload
to Nearline or Coldline,
when you delete the chunks
you do incur what we call
Early Deletion Penalty.
So download has
the same benefits.
So retry, so we do have retry
logic for transient network
failures.
There are more details here.
I'm not going to go into
each and every line.
And then there's something
called a manifest file.
So we can generate a manifest
file automatically when we run.
And the manifest
file will indicate,
you can see the example there,
of which objects or files were
successfully transferred,
and then failures as well.
All And the manifest file
itself can be used as an input
into gsutil, so you can do
an autoretry of failures.
So a lot of customers
use it that way.
In a lot of cases, because we
are now running HTTP requests,
sometimes there are failures.
So for whatever reason,
a file is not uploaded.
So you can use the
manifest files in input
to make sure that if you have a
million files, that all of them
are actually
uploaded effectively.
There's also resumability.
So there's automatic
for large objects.
And then there's the
resume file that we
use to track like
uploads in process.
So if there's block
for whatever reason,
we can do a resume
using this data.
So tips and tricks, I think that
the key one is the first bullet
point.
So if you have lots of
data, a huge data set,
you want the partition
that data set and use
multiple host for transfers.
Multiple host being like
physical machines or VMs.
And each one will run its
own instance of gsutil,
uploading a section
of your data source.
What this does is that
then you effectively has
a whole bunch of
gsutil instances
and threads uploading the
data at the same time, kind
of saturating your network
as much as possible.
We don't have any
network throttling,
so you have to kind of use
other tricks like, trickle,
or enforce the bandwidth
utilization at the network
layer.
If you're concerned about
POSIX metadata at all,
there's a -P option
that was recently
introduced to capture the
POSIX attributes of your source
files, and stored
it as a GCS metadata
as part of the
object that's in GCS.
So gsutil itself is a
relatively basic tool.
We don't do kind of like
network optimization.
So if you want even
better transfer speeds,
we have partners to [INAUDIBLE],
Cloud Fastpath, Aspera,
BitSpeed.
So some of them they do
UDP or TCB optimization
for better speeds.
All right so what
if your data sources
are at locations with a low
bandwidth or no bandwidth
at all?
So the solution is
offline data transfer,
or offline import-export,
well, import in this case.
So what this means is that
you have a physical storage
media with the hard drives,
so storage appliance.
You load the data and then ship
the hardware to an injection
point with good network.
And someone there will ingest
the data to GCS for you.
We have several third
party providers to do this.
We launched this collaboration
about a year and a half ago.
So in North America,
we have Iron Mountain.
You can see the pricing here.
In EMEA and APAC we're
Prime Focus Technologies.
So we have a bunch of
customers using these services.
Customers essentially sign up
with these third-party service
providers, separately
from Google.
Now a lot of use
cases where data
is generated offline, for
example, at C, collected
on hard drives, so when the
ship reaches port, what they do
is that they ship the hard
drive so Iron Mountain get
the data ingested.
It's not necessarily
a lot of data,
sometimes we are talking
about gigabytes or hundreds
of gigabytes of data.
But you know, when
you're out at sea,
generally you can't
even send one byte
if you don't have network.
So they kind of use
this offline method.
Now what's new here
is that we just
started working
with Zadara to offer
offline migration of live data.
They have a booth
downstairs if you guys want
to talk to them about this.
So how this works is
that they will send you
like two appliances.
You capture the data
onto the appliances.
You ship one to the Zadara.
They will upload to GCS.
And then they will use
the second appliance
to do synchronization of
data that has changed.
So if you're thinking about
the hard drive approach,
basically you're taking a
snapshot loading of their data,
loading into the hard
drive, shipping it out.
But what if your data evolves?
So Zadara kind of
solves that problem.
And because they are
using storage appliances,
you could capture
a lot more data
than on an individual
10 terabyte hard drive.
So as a summary, so we
have Transfer Service
for Cloud Data, gsutil
and partner products
for data in locations
with good network.
If you don't have a lot of data,
say under 100 terabytes or so,
you can use like
hard drive imports,
because if you have more data,
then the number of hard drives
become kind of unmanageable.
And we have more
data or live data,
then there's Zadara for you.
All right, so let's
cover structured data.
Now structured data is
more a partner play.
So we have a number of partners
who can help you migrate data
from on premise
databases, or even
other Cloud Databases to
Cloud SQL and Spanner.
So we have Informatica, Xplenty,
support both flavors of Cloud
SQL, MySQL and Postgres.
Segment, Stitch, Talend, and
Alooma support Postgres, SQL,
and Dbvisit, Attunity
supports MySQL only.
Similarly, if you are
interested in importing data
into Dataproc, we have a whole
bunch of partners for that.
And depending on where
you want to land data,
whether on GCS or
persistent disk,
we have different
partners supporting
the different targets.
So finally BigQuery data
integration partner,
and so again, partner
play, right generally,
everything from where
[INAUDIBLE] data sources.
So those marketing CRM
data sources, databases
like MySQL, SQL server,
Postgres, Oracle,
or data warehouses
like Teradata,
particularly [INAUDIBLE].
Now BigQuery is becoming
very popular with marketeers,
so you can use BigQuery to
analyze the click rates,
and all that to
kind of figure out
like whether you're advertising
campaign is effective.
So we just announced BigQuery
data Transfer Service.
And that basically
allows you to import data
from Google Ad Platforms
into BigQuery for analysis.
Now we also support other
sources of marketing data,
so whether Adobe Analytics,
Facebook, Twitter and so on,
through our panel ecosystem.
So you can check
out the link here.
This basically is pretty
update it to kind of like
give you an idea of which
partners are available to do
this data import.
And then reach out
to your rep as well
if you have additional needs.
So I've covered unstructured
data and structured data.
Let's talk about IT
workflow perspective.
This is actually a summary
of the talk I had yesterday,
just about 3, 4 slides.
So IT workflows are
generally things
like bursting, caching,
backup disaster recovery,
curing and archiving.
How can IT start running
these standard workflows?
How can they get
data onto the Cloud?
So Cloud Bursting, what's that?
So Cloud Bursting
is essentially you
are running
workloads on premise,
in your own data centers.
And you want to take
advantage of what
we can offer in the Cloud
for compute, for example
like low cost,
scale, even failover.
And then you care
about making sure
that the data that
is on premise is
available to the compute
workloads in the Cloud.
And then you don't have the
big hassle of explicitly
moving data around.
We partner with
Avere, for example.
They are really
great for compute,
high performance compute because
they allow you to store data
on premise, make the data
available for computing
instances in the Cloud
or vice versa, which
is you have data in the Cloud
taking advantage of low cost
GCS, and then
allowing on premise
compute to access the
data that is in the Cloud.
So to talk about backup, so
if you have an existing backup
solutions, you can
very, very easily
retarget your backup
destination to the Cloud.
So we work with
partners like Veritas
and so on, and its
just a UI change.
You can see the example
here on the right.
And then if you don't have
existing backup solutions,
we again, we are working
with a lot of our partners
that will support us today.
So you can talk to them.
If you don't have
existing backup solutions
but then your workflow or
data set is very simple,
then you can use like
Cloud Gateway Solutions.
Again, we have a lot of partners
that will support you on that.
Cloud-tiering is interesting.
So there are two ways of
looking at Cloud-tiering.
Well generally one way of
looking at Cloud-tiering, which
is you have data on
premise, storage where
you hold all of your data.
Now the problem with
on-premise storage
is that it is very expensive.
So why not move
some of that data
to Cloud, to take
advantage of our scale
and low cost, especially
like Coldline for example?
And so you can make space
for an additional live data
on premise.
So we have a partner
called Comprise
that can do an analysis of
your data usage on premise.
And they can identify which
data is kind of like cold data.
And it can then help you move
that data across to the Cloud,
based on policy and so on.
Another way of doing it is if
you are onboarding new storage
devices or storage
technologies, you
can go with the on premise
object storage vendors,
like Cloud [INAUDIBLE].
And they do automatic
tiering, and so
making sure that the
colder data automatically
gets tiered to GCS.
So a summary here is
that for whatever kind of
IT workflows that you have, and
if you want to leverage a Cloud
or even explore moving some
of the data to the Cloud,
we have the whole ecosystem
of partners for that.
OK so wrap up, if there's
one thing to remember
is this slide.
So we have different data
sources, different data
generation, and destinations,
and what are the solutions.
OK so everything from S3, to
IT workflows, Cloud Storage
Databases, Cloud SQL for
example, and partner solutions,
Transfer Service, and so on.
So if you are planning
to ingest data into GCP,
reach out to your sales rep.
There's a lot of things
that we are doing that we
can't talk about publicly.
So your sales rep may be
able to kind of like talk
to you more on the NDA about
all the stuff that we are doing.
As a PM responsible
for ingestion,
I want to make sure that you
guys are successful moving
a data into Cloud,
so where you have,
again, data ingestion
projects and so on,
reach out to your sales rep.
They'll get back to me.
And then we can
potentially work together.
All right, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]